It all Began 1200 years
ago in the Elven Golden Era
before the arrival of humans
and monsters in the world
I've taken control of the entire continent
faced with chaos the people will always
choose order no matter the cost seven Warriors
because strangers to each other bound together
to fight an Unstoppable Empire they're
under the Empire we need to rise up
it's that thing my Beast has done well
that's why I'd kill you for the cross Parts again
by the blade we have a chance if we do it together
it's between worlds the Gateway
the end of our world is upon us
we need to use it Beast against
him we merge the creature's power with one of you
come on Big Lots we're only just getting started
to the end to the end
there'll be no coming back
you're a Bard I am a Storyteller I
need you to sing a story back to life
are you sure you've got the right man for this
world's lead Worlds the locks most precious notes
shall be the key to All Things winter fans are
conversing and fully understand the conjunction
of spheres being the merging of the worlds where
Monsters and Men ended up in the content Domino
of The Witcher let's just say I'm one for a good
story I just wanted to play with those unanswered
questions where you're always going what happened
in the world pre-conjunction so we were taking it
up to that moment it's the month that leads up to
there and we explain the mechanics of it and the
tragic tale of how it came to be strap your tits
it's set on the same continent that we know from
series one and series two of The Witcher but it
takes place 1200 years before in the world
of blood origin they don't know of monsters
and they're meeting the elves at the height of
their empire the cities are huge and wonderful
it's a high culture High art science and Magic
are meeting so it's very very different in the
world of The Witcher you will also notice that
the map is slightly different we have the Three
Kingdoms prishia Centralia and Darwin each one
of them has their own Clan to protect Royals
we have the dog fan the serpent Clan then we
have the ravenclan the Clans are a special
guard that answer to no one they just protect
the kings and queens of these three kingdoms
and so we come in in a world that's kind of in
Strife there's a civil war going on between the
Elves and the Three Kingdoms that's lasted for
over a thousand years just feminating the land and
resources are not as great and all these wonderful
cities they had are starting to feel the attrition
the calamitous event takes place that draws
together two Warriors from opposing Clans on
a quest for vengeance Ayla I'm Phil doesn't
even look like me Australian yes for your
eyes and that's the start of our adventure
as they go we need Revenge by the blade
for the blade
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will
be my Witcher blood origin trailer video
also explained what happened with Henry Cavill
quitting The Witcher like why he is leaving the
show if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the episodes The Blood origin
series is meant to be a one-off like it's a real
quick shorter series it's just going to tell the
origin of the witchers like it literally says in
the title blood origin which is also meant to be
a reference to the Elder blood origins of The
Witcher potions used to create members of their
order give them their special powers which they
referenced during season two when vesimir wanted
to use ciri to recreate The Witcher potion there
was another Witcher movie called nightmare of the
wolf that they released last year that detailed
what happened to the school of the wolf why they
lost the ability to create more witchers why
they lost the original potion that allow them
to do that the trial the grasses vesimir learned
that his former instructor delgan had been using
Witcher Alchemy to create new monsters so that
the surrounding cities would need The Witcher
Services more keeping their way of life secure
the town's people rebelled against them using a
mage in a small army and basically destroyed the
school that's why the keep has been in Ruins ever
since then when that happened all their special
potions were destroyed and the people who knew
how to create more so that's why in present day
you don't see more witchers being created like
even though ciri is being trained as a Witcher
she can't actually become one because they don't
have the potion to create more but the thing
is is that she doesn't need to become a Witcher
she doesn't need those special powers because
she's already got so much power from her Elder
blood she's meant to be like the most powerful
character in the world on the show in present
day so she's kind of like a Witcher like she gets
all the Witcher training but she's not literally
a Witcher she hasn't gone through the trial the
grass is the same way that geralt did the blood
origin series is meant to take place 1200 years
ago before the events of the main series just
before the first conjunction of the Spheres that
gets into the origin of the wild Hunt as well like
you'll learn the origin of the witchers but also
the origin of the wild hunt the king of the wild
Hunt is meant to be the main villain of the show
but there's like a whole backstory behind the wild
Hunt itself they used to be called the red Riders
they come from a different planet but they're part
of the group of elves that splintered off years
ago and just inhabited another planet we got a
teaser for the wild Hunt at the end of season
two when ciri opened the portal to that other
world where they come from they'll become much
bigger characters later on in the main series
they're not that big in the story right now but
the reason why the wild Hunt are like the main
antagonist in the overall Witcher series like the
entire series is because ciri's Elder blood is
the culmination of this long time program created
by the separate group of elves that the wild Hunt
comes from it was their way of creating a perfect
being with so much power that they could stop the
white Frost which was sort of their prophecy about
this coming of a great ice age that would destroy
the entire planet but early on in their program
people who weren't supposed to get married and
have children wound up getting married and having
children so that's how the Elder blood passed from
the elves to the humans like ciri is literally
biologically part elf through her great great
great great many times over grandmother she was
the daughter of the king of the group of elves
that the wild hung comes from so on the show we're
supposed to meet that separate group of elves even
though during these trailers they just give you a
teaser for three groups of elves three different
factions of elves on the main World Of The Witcher
remember the whole idea is the group that the wild
Hunt comes from those elves actually left the
planet using these special Obelisk these Gates
a long time ago before the events of the series
pick up and it's when the first conjunction of
the Spheres happened that they planned their next
Invasion to come back so technically there's like
four groups of elves on the show if you include
the group that the wild Hunt comes from but the
king of the wild Hunt has his own plans for Ciri
and her Elder blood the power that it contains he
wants to use her power to conquer other worlds the
whole idea is that you need these special obelisks
but you can only open gates with special power
what wound up happening to that separate group
of elves that they come from is that a long time
ago they lost the ability to travel Between Worlds
at will and they had to wait for the first
conjunction of the Spheres to do it again
and in the present day of the show 1200 years
later they had to wait for the next conjunction
of the Spheres before they could do it another
time but the show is also meant to show you how
the elves on the main World Of The Witcher went
from being the most powerful race until present
day when they're a shouted their former selves and
the humans all rule the world like in present day
ciri's father Emperor Emhyr is trying to unite the
world under a single human Banner under his banner
I know a lot of you are asking what's going on
with jaskier being pulled back in time by what
seems like many drivers Elven character another
big Cameo scene here it seems like she wants him
to play an ancient song in present day that's
been forgotten a tale about the story of the
wild Hunt the origin of the witchers to remind
everyone in present day about the conjunction
of the spheres and the danger that it poses in
the prophecy about Ciri the whole idea that she
is the culmination of this elder blood program
that's going to stop the white Frost eventually
but I know a lot of you are asking what happened
with Henry Cavill why did he quit the show season
three is going to be his last season and then in
season four it's going to be Liam Hemsworth of
all people that was actually a big surprise when
I heard that wait a minute William Hemsworth that
seems like a big change there have been a lot of
rumors a lot of speculation It's a combination
of factors it isn't just Superman coming back
in the DC movies that cause Henry Cavill leave
Black Adam we should talk one of the biggest
reasons was just the time commitment of the
series keeping Henry Cavill from doing more
movies is true Netflix could have tried to
toss more coins at that Witcher but it turns out
that they did not toss a coin to your Witcher over
Valentino they've been a lot of reports about
Henry Cavill being unhappy about the direction
of the story that The Witcher was taking because
they're making a lot of changes to the bookstorey
to adapt it for television I think people are
playing that up just a little bit just because
it sounds so dramatic I'm sure there are a few
things that he disagrees with about the direction
of the show and it does sound like what they're
planning to do in the next couple of seasons like
it run maybe five seasons total is that eventually
it will become more of a show centered around the
ciri character which is kind of what's happening
in The Witcher games right now like they announced
The Witcher 4 that's mostly going to be a ciri
game I don't want to get too much into the plot
of the games because that takes place after the
events of the books and they're just adapting the
books for the show and because the books came
out so long ago we already know what happens
to geralt's character at the end of The Witcher
books please don't post spoilers for that in the
comments if you have read of the books or you
know the story in order for him to come back in
the first Witcher game which takes place after
the end of the books they had to have this big
retcon just for the purposes of the game and in
reality Henry cavill's long-term plan and when he
signed on for The Witcher to begin with was only
to do a couple Seasons like he never planned on
going Beyond three seasons so even if he weren't
coming back as Superman in the DC Universe which
is great really happy that's happening had The
Witcher continued on to season four season five
and Beyond he would have left the show no matter
what so like Netflix the showrunner everybody
that's making the show probably knew he was going
to leave a long time ago and they just waited to
announce it till now like it would have been weird
if they would announce that a couple seasons ago
when they first started the show like oh by the
way Henry Cavill he's gonna quit about halfway
through and we're going to bring out another actor
to replace him what my plan is right now is that
I'll just do regular videos for Witcher season
three I'll do a video for the blood Origins just
to explain what's going on during the series and
then when we get to The Witcher season four we'll
just see how it goes and how everybody responds
to it obviously people are going to be upset
about Henry Cavill leaving but like I said it's
mostly just about Henry Cavill wanting more time
to do bigger movies and just not being able to do
that while he's tied up doing a series every year
so you can blame a little bit of him coming back
as Superman of the DC movies but not completely
all the episodes for The Witcher bullet origin
will be dropping really soon I'll do at least
one video for all the episodes if you have any big
questions about the lore or the series or what's
going on just write them in the comments below and
everyone click here for my brand new Guardians of
the Galaxy 3 trailer video and click here for
my brand new Ant-Man and the Wasp Quantumania
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!